[Music]
Ozzie is on record as saying that he
loves love's loves Taylor Swift he does
okay are you ever worried that we need
to show up what who Taylor Swift is this
a picture of the aforementioned
celebrity to help you
everyone knows who Taylor Swift is
anyway do you ever okay are you worried
that maybe Ozzy would be tempted by
Taylor Swift that he would cheat with
Taylor Swift oh well this is a
legitimate question yeah course not
she's a lovely young girl and he just
happens to think that she is a great
example he thinks that she's really
beautiful and talented and that she's
like she takes her success she deals
with it very well
yes she does and he admires her oh he
admires her okay I'm sure he I mean in
another life maybe but I mean come on
that's a ridiculous question
do you think it's a ridiculous question
Andy pretty may-september here you know
on a September
[Laughter]